l'autorité paternelle a fait place à
l'autorité parentale 4 juin 1970 la loi
relative à l'autorité parentale est
adoptée par l'assemblée nationale
pour la première fois les décisions
concernant l'éducation des enfants sont
partagés entre la mère et le père à
parts égales les pouces devient un peu
plus légal de son mari son autorisation
sera suffisante pour les actes habituel
de gestion du ménage et d'éducation des
enfants
en clair inscrire son enfant à l'école
ou autoriser une intervention
chirurgicale
c'est désormais possible pour la mer et
ce sans l'accord du père mais à
condition d'être mariée vous avez eu le
privilège d'avoir les nouveaux articles
du code civil
derrière cette loi une femme l'avocate
anne marie bourland rollier cette
autorité parentale n'est pas exercée par
le père sol durant le mariage mais
conjointement par les deux des coûts
pour être tout à fait franche en fait
c'est ce qui existe déjà dans tous les
ménages qui s'entendent bien
mais je crois que c'est tout de même
très important que maintenant on le
disent dans la loi au début des années
70 la société évolue les modes de vie
changent les femmes s'émancipent c'est
l'une des conséquences de mai 68 dans
l'éducation familiale aussi le rôle a
changé selon simone veil alors
magistrate c'est ainsi que de plus en
plus la femme a pris une part
prépondérante dans l'éducation des
enfants et qu'elle ne laisse plus son
mari s'occuper seul et régler seul un
certain nombre de questions qui
concernent aussi bien la maison que
surtout lorsqu'il au jeu nous intéresse
aujourd'hui le les rapports des parents
et des enfants
grâce à cette loi les notions de
puissance paternelle et de chef de
famille sont supprimés je trouve que
c'est une chose ce top est logique c'est
tout à fait normal qu'elle est amené les
auteurs de ce recul
il faut attendre janvier 1971 pour que
la loi entre en application article 213
les époux assurent ensemble la direction
morale et matérielle de la famille en
1993 une nouvelle loi est adoptée cette
année là l'autorité parentale partagée
devient la règle pour tous les parents
qu'ils soient divorcés séparés ou non
mariés
[Musique]